hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and tomorrow for
property investors
could be a very interesting day they are
talking about abolishing
stamp duty tax tomorrow they're talking
about abolishing it
for a certain period of time we don't
know how long that's going to be
maybe they'll abolish stamp duty tax
just for six months maybe a couple years
i don't know
no one knows exactly what's going to
happen how is it going to affect buy to
let investors
i imagine they're going to abolish stamp
duty tax all together they're saying
that unless you're going to buy a house
that's 500 000 pounds half a million or
above
they're going to give people a break
when buying houses
and not charge stamp duty tax
now why are they doing that and what's
that gonna do well if you remember i did
my prediction video
just a few weeks back where i made 12
property predictions
and about the economy and one of the
predictions that i made just a couple
weeks back
was that the government are going to try
and introduce ways for people to start
spending more money trying to get the
economy going again i said they're going
to try and get us buying
they're going to try and get a spending
the government are going to start
encouraging spending like crazy the
government are going to be saying spend
spend spend
they're going to be encouraging spending
over the next three six months because
they want the economy to pick back up
and when people are not making money and
when people are not spending money
what happens is the government get less
money as well because of taxes
see if i make some money right now i
charge you for my product
and i make some money and then i use
that money to spend money
they get the government are winning tax
tax tax they're getting taxed but when
i'm not making money and i'm not
spending money the government aren't
making money and if the government
aren't making money the government are
not happy
they're going to be encouraging like
crazy you to spend spend spans
and this is just one of my predictions
already beginning to unravel and come
true
because what they're trying to do is
because there was over half a million
properties that were frozen from selling
they're trying to encourage properties
to sell so that's
why they're doing it they don't want the
dip to happen because they don't want
the economy to be damaged
following on the coronavirus how is it
going to affect you and how should you
prepare for it well what i'll probably
say is
don't be one of these people that say
i'm gonna wait for properties to bottom
out
i'm gonna just wait and see what happens
you can't afford
to just wait and see what happens i said
this again
two weeks ago when property prices were
like
unsure and people say they're going to
rock it they're going to rock it they're
going to rock it
and people and then everyone was saying
i'm just going to hold off i'm just
going to hold back
well don't do that don't be that person
i don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow i don't know what's going to be
announced tomorrow
but my advice is just to buy the right
properties
at the right prices and make sure that
it cash flows positive
the only thing okay that would worry me
a little bit
would be if tomorrow and this could
happen this wouldn't surprise me
because i know how sometimes backward
the government are with their
announcements
and stuff but if they bring in the
stamjui holiday
but say that it's not going to start
straight away it's going to start from
october which they are talking about
they're saying that they're going to
bring it in but it might not start till
the autumn i think that'll be a really
stupid move on the government's part i'm
just going to put it out now and say it
now because here's what will happen
if they say we're going to bring in a
stamp duty holiday which starts in
october
no one's going to want to buy before
october everyone's going to say oh well
we'll wait until october then and that's
going to cause a bigger problem
because it's going to cause a massive
freeze in the market just like we had
two months ago when everything was
when everything was in lockdown so
government
if you're watching this video if you're
going to announce the stamp duty holiday
at least make it happen immediately
otherwise don't announce it
don't announce it because the last thing
we need right now
is another freezing of house sales
happening because i tell you something
i've just sold some houses i've got one
or two more that i'm in the process of
selling
i'm buying houses we don't want to be
messed around like that so
i hope that they don't do that if they
do do that
there'll be some very sinister agenda
behind it i'm sure because that would be
really damaging
i'd love to know what you think though
what do you think about the stamp duty
holiday do you think it's going to
happen
how do you think it's going to happen do
you think it's going to affect buy to
let investors do you think it's going to
start immediately do you think they're
going to make us wait till the autumn
if they make us wait till the autumn do
you agree with me that that's going to
cause a massive freeze
i'd love to know what you think comment
below and as soon as the announcement is
made i'll be planning another video
and telling you what's happened how it's
going to affect you and how you can
maximize as a property investor
from the changes thanks so much for
watching if you enjoy my videos please
do
demolish the like button you know smash
that like button we want to see the
thumb
we want to see it blue it needs to be
little blue make that happen
also if you're not already subscribed to
the channel subscribe turn the
notification bell on because you do not
want to miss
these news updates around property
because ultimately this stuff
you watch the news it's going to be
interesting you watch my youtube channel
it's going to help you become wealthy
it's going to help you become
financially free in property so
subscribe turn the notification bell on
and i'll see you tomorrow what's
happening tomorrow
i've got a winner's wednesday tomorrow's
wednesday so i'm going to be
interviewing
lee lawrence tomorrow who's been in
property for 17 years
and picking his brand about property and
how i've helped him in his journey as
well if you can't wait until tomorrow
and you want to watch videos right now
then you can check out the whole
playlist of my winners every single week
i take someone who's become financially
free or successful in property i
interview them you can hear their
stories there's a whole bunch right here
and if you want to learn about how
serviced accommodation is very tax
efficient you want to save tax i did a
video yesterday if you've not seen it go
check it out right here
of course don't forget to subscribe over
here do that now if you don't subscribe
bad things will happen to you